un divorce n'a pas envie de laisser
venir mon couple ah ouais non merci des
coupes qui font semblant sont parlés
semblant de s'écouter à jour et à 10
enfants prennent ça comme on essaie
surtout de poser sur mathias colonies
dans 15 ans voulu passer tout à cette
conne avec lequel on peut voir le plus
de discussions puisque les masses est
plus compliquée elle a 13 ans touchons
là d un truc un train c'est vraiment une
aiguille je vous déteste avec moi ce qui
compte c'est qu'on a c'est une famille
unie par l'amour même si plus on aime
toi c'est magnifique et julien qu'est ce
que tu vois là un peu sec
julien je rappelle que dans neuf ans
enfin voila c'est joyeux quoi quand
est-ce qu'on devra décider si c'est papa
ou maman on va
paris est le seul décisions importantes
on va prendre son torrent tranquille au
monde samedi quoi servent les ont battus
moi même